i look forward to it
thank you and good night
president lyndon johnson delivered his
final state of the union address to
congress on january 14 1969
less than a week before the inauguration
of his successor republican richard
nixon the speech served as his goodbye
to the american people as he did not
give a farewell speech
president johnson spoke about what he
saw as his accomplishments including the
passage of the voting rights act and the
creation of medicare
and he expressed hope that negotiations
would result in peace in vietnam
our coverage of the 50-minute address
comes from cbs news
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my distinguished colleagues of the
congress i have the high privilege
and the distinct honor
not only officially but personally to me
are presenting to you
the president
of the united states
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice figure
[Music]
thank you very much mr speaker
mr president
members of the congress and my fellow
americans
for the sixth
and the last time
i present to the congress
my assessment of the state of the union
i shall speak to you tonight
about
challenge and opportunity
and about the commitments that
all of us have made together
that will
if we carry them out
give america
our best chance to achieve
the kind of a great society that we all
want
every president lives not only with what
is
but with what has been
and what could be
most of the great events in his
presidency
are part of a larger sequence
extending back through several years
and
extending back through several other
administrations
urban unrest
poverty
pressures on welfare
education of our people
law enforcement and law and order
the continuing crisis in the middle east
the conflict in vietnam
the dangers of nuclear war
the
great difficulties of dealing with the
communist powers
all
have this much in common
they
and their causes
the causes that gave rise to them
all of these have existed
with us for many years
several presidents have already sought
to
try to deal with them
one or more presidents will try to
resolve them
or try to contain them
in the years that are ahead of us
but if the nation's problems are
continuing
so are
this great nation's assets
our economy the democratic system
our sense of exploration symbolized most
recently by the wonderful flight of the
apollo 8 in which all americans took
great pride
[Applause]
[Music]
and the
good common sense and sound judgment
of the american people
and their essential love
of justice
we must not ignore our problems but
neither should we
ignore
our strengths
those strengths are available to sustain
a president of either party
to support his progressive efforts
both at home and overseas
unfortunately the departure of an
administration
does not mean the end of the problems
that this administration has faced
the effort to meet the problems must go
on
year after year
if the momentum that we have all mounted
together
in these past years is not to be lost
although the
struggle for progressive change is
continuous
there are times when a watershed is
reached
when there is if
not really a break with the past
at least the fulfillment
of many of its oldest hopes
and a stepping forth into a new
environment
to seek new goals
and i think the past five years have
been such a time
we have finished a major part of the old
agenda
some of the laws that we wrote have
already
in front of our eyes taken on the flesh
of achievement
medicare that we were unable to pass for
so many years is now a part
of american life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
voting rights and the voting booth that
we debated so long
back in the 50s
and the doors to public servants
are open at last to
all americans regardless of their color
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
schools and school children
all over america tonight
are receiving federal assistance to go
to good schools
and preschool education head start
is already here to stay
and i think so are the federal programs
that
tonight are keeping more than a million
and a half of our
of our young people
in the colleges and universities of this
country
[Applause]
part of the american earth
not only in description on a map
but in the reality of our shores and our
hills and our parks and our forests and
our mountains
has been permanently set aside
for the american public
and for their benefit
[Applause]
[Music]
and there's more going to be set aside
before this administration ends
[Applause]
[Music]
five million americans have been trained
for jobs in
new federal programs
and
i think it's most important that we all
realize tonight
that this nation is close to full
employment
with less unemployment than we've had at
any time in almost 20 years
[Applause]
and that's not in theory that's in fact
tonight the unemployment rate is down to
3.3 percent the number of jobs has grown
more than eight and a half million in
the last five years
and that's more
and that's more than in all the
preceding 12 years
these achievements
completed the full cycle
from idea to enactment
and finally to a place in the lives of
citizens all across this country
i wish it were possible to say that
everything that
this congress and the administration
achieved during this period had already
completed that cycle
but a great deal of what we have
committed needs additional funding to
become a tangible realization
and yet
the very existence of these commitments
these promises to the american people
made by this congress and by the
executive branch of the government
our achievements in themselves
and failure to carry through on our
commitments
would be a tragedy for this nation
this much is certain
no one man or group of men
made these commitments alone
congress
and the executive branch for their
checks and balances
reasoned together
and finally wrote them into the law of
the land
and they now have all the moral force
that the american political system
can summons when it acts as one
they express america's common
determination
to achieve goals
they imply action
in most cases
you have already begun that action
but it is not fully completed of course
let me speak for a moment about these
commitments and i'm going to speak in
the language which the congress itself
spoke when it passed these measures i'm
going to quote
from your word
in 1966 congress declared
that improving the quality of urban life
is the most critical domestic problem
facing the united states
two years later
it affirmed the historic gold of a
decent home
for every american family that's your
language
now to meet these commitments
we must increase our support for the
model cities program where blueprints of
change are already being prepared in
more than 150 american
cities to achieve the goal of the
housing act of 1968 that you just passed
we should
begin this year
more than
500 000 homes
for needy families in the coming fiscal
year
and funds are provided in the new budget
to do just this
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is almost 10 times
10 times the average rate
of the past 10 years
our cities and our towns are
being pressed for funds to meet the
needs of their growing population
so i believe an urban development bank
should be created by the congress
this bank could obtain resources through
the issuance of taxable bonds
and it could then lend these resources
at reduced rates
to
the communities throughout the land for
schools and hospitals and parks
and other public facilities
since we enacted the social security act
back in 1935
congress has recognized the necessity
to make more adequate provision for aged
persons and maternal and child welfare
and public health
and that
the words of the congress
more adequate in the time has come i
think to make it more adequate
and i believe we should increase
social security benefits and i'm so
recommending that
[Applause]
[Music]
suggesting that there should be an
overall increase in benefits of at least
thirteen percent
and those who receive only the minimum
fifty five dollars should get
eighty dollars a month
our nation
ii is rightfully proud of our medical
advances
but we should remember that our country
ranks 15th among the nations of the
world in its infant mortality rate
i think we should assure decent medical
care
for every expectant mother and for their
children during the first year of their
life in the united states of america
[Music]
i think we should protect our children
and their families from the cost
of catastrophic illness
[Applause]
and as we pass on from medicine i think
nothing is clearer to the congress than
the commitment that the congress made to
end poverty
congress expressed it well i think in
1964 when they said
it is the policy of the united states
to eliminate the paradox of poverty in
the midst of plenty
in this nation
this the richest nation in the world
the anti-poverty program has had many
achievements
it also has some failures
but we must not [ __ ] it after only
three years of trying to solve the human
problems
that have been with us and have been
building up among us for generations
i believe the congress this year will
want to improve the administration the
poverty program
by reorganizing portions of it and
transferring them to other agencies
i believe though it will want to
continue until we have broken the back
of poverty
the efforts we're now making
throughout this land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i believe and i hope the next
administration i believe they believe
is that the key to success in this
effort
is jobs
is work for people who want to work
in the budget for fiscal 1970 i shall
recommend a total of
3 billion 500 million dollars for our
job training program and that's five
times as much as we spent in 1964 trying
to prepare americans where they can work
to earn their own living
[Music]
the nation's commitment in the field of
civil rights began with the declaration
of independence
they were extended by the 13th and 14th
and 15th amendments
and they have been powerfully
strengthened by the enactment of three
far-reaching civil rights laws within
the past five years that this congress
and its wisdom passed
on january the first of this year the
fair housing act of 1968 covered over 20
million
american homes and apartments
the prohibition against racial
discrimination
in that act
should be remembered
and it should be vigorously enforced
throughout this land
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i believe we should also extend the
vital provisions of the voting rights
act
for another five years
[Applause]
in the safe streets acts of 1968
congress
determined
to assist state and local governments in
reducing the incidence of crime
this year i am proposing that the
congress provide the full 300 million
dollars that the congress last year
authorized to do just that
[Applause]
and i hope the congress will put the
money where the authorization is
[Applause]
[Music]
i believe this is an essential
contribution to justice and the public
order in the united states
and i hope these grants can be made to
the states
and they can be used effectively
to reduce the crime rate in this country
but all of this is only a small part of
the total effort that must be made i
think chiefly
by the local governments throughout the
nation
if we expect to reduce the toll of crime
that we all
detest
frankly as i leave the office of the
presidency one of my greatest
disappointments
is our failure to secure passage of a
licensing and registration act for
firearms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think if we had passed that act it
would have reduced the incidence of
crime
and i believe that the congress should
adopt such a law
and i hope that it will
at a not too distant date
[Applause]
in order to meet our long-standing
commitment to make government as
efficient as possible
i believe that we should reorganize our
postal system along the lines of the
capitol report
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i hope we can all agree that public
service
should never impose an unreasonable
financial sacrifice
on able men and women who want to serve
their country
so i believe that the recommendations of
the
commission on executive legislative and
judicial salary
are generally sound
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
later this week i shall submit a special
message which i reviewed with the
leadership this evening
containing a proposal that
has been reduced and
has modified the commission's
recommendation to some extent
on
the
congressional salaries
for members of congress i will recommend
the basic compensation not of the 50 000
unanimously recommended by
the capital commission and
the other distinguished members but
i shall reduce that fifty thousand to
forty two thousand five hundred dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
and i will suggest that congress
appropriate a very small additional
allowance for official expenses so that
members will not be required to use
their salary increase
for essential official business
[Applause]
[Music]
i would have submitted the commission's
recommendations except
the advice that i received from the
leadership and you usually
are consulted about matters that affect
the congress
was that the congress would not accept
the 50 000 recommendation and if i
expected my recommendation to be
seriously considered i should make
substantial reductions that's the only
reason i didn't go along with the
capitol report
in 1967 i recommended the congress a
fair and impartial random selecting
system for the draft
i submitted again tonight for your most
respectful consideration
[Applause]
[Music]
and i know that all of us recognize that
most of the things we do to meet all of
these commitment i talk about will cost
money
and if we maintain the strong rate of
growth that we've had in this country
for the past eight years
i think we shall generate this resources
that we need to meet these commitments
we've already been able to increase our
support for major major social programs
although we've heard a lot about not
being able to do anything on the home
front because of vietnam
but we have been able
in the last five years to increase
our commitments for such things as
health and education
from 30 billions
in 1964
to 68 billion dollars
in the coming fiscal year that's more
than double
and that's more than it's ever been
increased in the 188 years of this
republic notwithstanding vietnam
[Applause]
[Music]
we must continue to budget our resources
and budget them responsibly in a way
that will
preserve our prosperity and
will strengthen our dollar
greater revenues and
the reduced federal spending required by
congress last year
have changed the budgetary picture
dramatically since last january when we
made our estimates
at that time you'll remember that we
estimated we'd have a deficit of eight
billion dollars
well i'm glad to report to you tonight
that the fiscal year ending june 30th
1969 this june
we are
going to have not a deficit
but we're going to have
a
2 billion
400 million dollar circles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you will receive the budget tomorrow
but the budget for the next fiscal year
that begins next july the first
that you will want to examine very
carefully in the days ahead
it will provide a
3 billion
400 million dollar surplus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this budget anticipates the extension of
the surtax
that congress enacted
last year
i have communicated with the
president-elect nixon
in connection with
this policy
and continuing the surtax for the time
being
i want to tell you that both of us want
to see it removed just as soon as
circumstances will permit
but the president-elect has told me that
he has concluded
that until his administration
and this congress can examine the
appropriation bills and each item in the
budget and can ascertain
that the facts justify
permitting the surtax to expire or to
reduce
he mr nixon will support my
recommendation that the surtax be
continued
[Music]
[Applause]
americans i believe are united in the
hope that the parish talks will bring an
early peace to vietnam
and if our hopes from early settlement
of the war are realized then our
military expenditures can be reduced
and very substantial savings can be made
to be used
for other desirable purposes as the
congress may determine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in any event i think it's imperative
that we do all we responsibly can to
resist
inflation while maintaining our
prosperity
i think all americans know that our
prosperity is broad and it's deep
that it's brought record profits
the highest in our
history record wages
our gross national product has grown
more in the last five years any other
period in our nation's history our wages
have been the highest our profits have
been the best
and
this prosperity has enabled millions to
escape the poverty
that they would have otherwise
had
the last few years
and i think also you'll be very glad to
hear that
the secretary of treasury informs me
tonight that
in 1968
in our balance of payments
we have achieved a surplus
it appears that we have in fact
done better
this year than we've done in any year
in this regard since the year 1957.
[Applause]
[Music]
the quest for durable peace has i think
absorbed every administration since the
end of world war ii
it has required us to seek a limitation
of armed races
not only among the superpowers but among
the smaller nations as well
we have joined the test ban treaty of
1963.
the outer space treaty of 1967
the treaty against the spread of nuclear
weapons in 1968
and this latter agreement the
non-proliferation treaty is now pending
in the senate and it's been pending
there since last july
in my opinion delay in ratifying it is
not going to be helpful to the cause of
peace
america took the lead in negotiating
this treaty
and america should now take steps to
have it approved at the earliest
possible date
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and until away can be found to scale
down the level of arms among the
superpowers
mankind cannot view the future without
fear and great apprehension
so
i believe that we should resume the
talks with this soviet union about
limiting offensive and defensive missile
system and i think they would have
already been resumed except for
czechoslovakia and our election this
year
it was more than 20 years ago that we
embarked on a program
of trying to aid the developing nations
we knew then that we could not live in
good conscience as a rich enclave
on an earth that was seething in misery
and during these years there have been
great advances made under our program
particularly against want and hunger
and although we're disappointed at the
appropriations last year
we thought they were awfully inadequate
this year i'm asking for adequate funds
for economic assistance
and the hope that we can further peace
throughout the world
i think we must continue to support
efforts in regional cooperation
among those efforts that of western
europe has a very special place in
america's concern
the only course that's going to permit
europe to play the great role
the world role that its resources permit
is to go forward to unity
i think america remains ready to work
with the united europe
work as a partner on the basis of
equality
for our future
the quest for peace
i believe requires that we maintain the
liberal trade policies that have helped
us
become the leading nation in world trade
that we strengthen the international
monetary system as an instrument of
world prosperity and that we seek areas
of agreement with the soviet union where
the interests of both nations
and the interests of world peace
are properly served
the strained relationship between us and
the world's leading communist power has
not ended
especially in the light of the brutal
invasion of czechoslovakia
but totalitarianism is no less odious to
us
because we're able to reach some
accommodation that reduces the danger of
world catastrophe
what we do
we do in the interest of peace in the
world
and we
earnestly hope that time will bring a
russia
that is less afraid of adversity and
individual freedom
the
quest for peace tonight continues in
vietnam and in the parish talks
i
regret more than any of you know
that it has not been possible to restore
peace to south vietnam
the prospects i think for peace are
better today than at any time
since north vietnam began its invasion
into its regular forces
more than four years ago
[Applause]
and the free nations of asia know
what they were not sure of at that time
that america cares about their
freedom and it also cares about
america's own vital interests in asia
and throughout the pacific
[Applause]
[Music]
the north vietnamese know that they
cannot achieve their aggressive purposes
by force
there may be hard fighting before a
settlement is reached
but i can assure you it will yield no
victory
to the communist cause
i cannot speak to you tonight about
vietnam without paying a very
personal tribute
to the men who have
carried the battle
out there for all of us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and i have been honored
to be their commander-in-chief
[Applause]
the nation owes them its understanding
support while the battle continues
and its enduring gratitude
when their service is done
[Applause]
[Music]
finally the quest for stable peace in
the middle middle east goes on in many
capitals tonight
america fully supports the unanimous
resolution of the u.n security council
which points the way
there must be a settlement of the armed
hostility that exists
in that region the world today
it is a threat not only to israel
and to all the arab states
but it's a threat
to every one of us and to the entire
world as well
and now my friends in congress i want to
conclude with
a few very personal words to you
i rejected and
rejected and then finally accepted the
congressional leadership's invitation
to come here to
speak this farewell to you in person
tonight
i did that for two reasons
one was philosophical i wanted to give
you my judgment
as i saw it on some of the issues before
our nation
as i view them before i leave
the other was just pure sentimental
most of my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
most all of my life as a public official
has been spent here in this building
for 38 years since i worked
on that gallery as a door keeper
in the house of representatives
i have
i have known these halls and i have
known most of the men pretty well who
walk them
i know the questions that you face i
know the conflicts that you endure
i know the ideals that you seek to serve
i left here first to become vice
president
and then to become in a moment of
tragedy the president of the united
states
my term of office has been marked by
a series of challenges
both at home
and throughout the world
in meeting some of these challenges
the nation has found a new confidence
in meeting others
it knew turbulence
and doubt
and fear and hate
and throughout this time
i have been sustained
by my faith in representative democracy
a faith that i had learned here in this
capital building
as an employee and as a congressman
and as a senator
i believe deeply in the ultimate
purposes of this nation
described by the constitution
tempered by history
embodied in progressive laws
given
life
by men and women that have been elected
to serve
their fellow citizens
now for five most demanding years in the
white house
i have been strengthened by the council
and the cooperation of two
great former presidents
harry s truman and dwight david
eisenhower
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been guided by
the memory of
my pleasant and close association with
the beloved
john f kennedy
and with our greatest modern legislator
speaker sam rayburn
[Applause]
i have been assisted by my friend
every step of the way vice president
hubert humphrey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so grateful that i've been supported
daily
by the loyalty of speaker mccomic and
majority leader albert
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i have benefited from the wisdom
of senator mike mansfield
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm sure that i have avoided
many dangerous pitfalls
by the good common sense counsel of the
president pro tem of the senate senator
richard brevard russia
[Music]
[Applause]
i have received the most generous
cooperation
from the leaders
of the republican party in the congress
of the united states senator dirksen
and congressman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and congressman
gerald ford the majority
[Applause]
[Music]
no president
should ask for more although i did upon
occasion
but few presidents have ever been
blessed
with so much
president-elect nixon in the days ahead
is going to
need your understanding
just as i did
and he's entitled to have it
i hope every member will remember that
the burdens
he will bear as our president
will be born for
all of us
each of us should try not to increase
these burdens for the sake of nara
personal
or partisan advantage
[Applause]
[Music]
and now it's time to leave
i hope it may be said
a hundred years from now
that by working together
we help to make our country
more just
more just for all of its people
as well as to ensure
and guarantee the blessings of liberty
for all of our posterity
that's what i hope but i believe
that
at least it will be
said that we tried
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's taking a long time
[Applause]
[Music]
food
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
oh
wow